this is a production of cornell
university
sure uh thanks everybody the 20th
episode of the cornell turf show we're
going to go through here today
thanks everybody for sticking up with us
during the spring great feedback
so we appreciate everybody attending
live watching after the fact or
listening
uh today's guest dr rachel swa
university of nebraska-lincoln
uh rock's here today we're gonna talk
about some aeration uh it may get
controversial we don't know we'll see
um but it's it's we've been itching to
have a conversation for a couple weeks
weeks now so we're glad to get brock on
the show here um but as always frank uh
we'll transition to you uh with your
news and notes from the past week
all right thanks carl so good to have
everybody here and and
you know jeff stone and the guys at uh
at the ocean course at kiwa island big
shout out to the second major of the
year the crew you know it's always uh
great and i noticed uh you know the
great sky that you get down there in the
low country
i believe this is the low country and
then um
one of my favorite golf courses in the
world is this mackenzie little gem in
adelaide australia
that this picture showed up on twitter
not only with a beautiful sky but
you know among my most favorite things
to do other than yak with my esteemed
colleague from nebraska is to ride
trains
and there's a train that goes right
through the heart of this golf course
and it's a very unique experience
for the person spraying on the left
there uh
enjoying a train going by um you know
lots of lots of stuff in this social
media world i i spend
and have had to spend my time on a new
account in twitter because i got hacked
and i started selling sunglasses for a
short period of time
but i always marvel at how
superintendents just notice little
things and even the crew members
you know talking about how you know the
simple task of raking a bunker can you
know bring
a lot of well-being and you know as mike
powell
paul mccormick would say some
peacefulness or mindfulness
in doing these tasks and i think that
gets lost a lot of times in the hustle
bustle and of course you can't
carl it's our last show right so i gotta
show the cute dog pictures right
um and then all the stupid stuff this
isaac brewer this was a great one
the twitter picture cropped it he goes
new water feature on 14. so i'm looking
at this thing carl and i'm saying oh
there's these rocks so it's probably a
rip-rap picture or something and then
you scan back and there's this poor guy
trying to fix a leak uh
on the side of the fairway and for those
of you that just can't get enough of
looking at my face carl face
uh our voices uh we've got the youtube
channel that's you know we've got to be
setting records carl for
throwing all kinds of baloney out there
from the land grant institution here in
new york
as well as a podcast right we we take
this
and and put it in another format for
those of people who just like to listen
to it in their head
now carl as i pass it back to you just a
reminder to everybody
we're going to be back with some
webinars over the next
couple of months i know it seems weird
to be doing it during the summer but
we're going to try to get some content
on screen with our colleague
rick slattery uh who's working with us
on this program
in partnership with the rochester
institute of technology the galasano
in sustainability institute and carl
um you know the sustainability website
is up there now
people can sign up and get the emails
and of course everybody knows wants a
poster carl
we want us people to start sending
pictures of their face like this
with the poster to the show let's let's
get an email account and
see if we can get uh somebody to outdo
you with with that grin on your face so
carl what's the tip for
what's the tip of the week yeah so we've
been doing this now for
for 11 weeks frank and each week we've
been taking one of these
you know aspects of the poster one of
these bmps kind of blowing them out and
looking at them
uh but today in kind of a prelude to the
talk we'll have with rock i wanted to
talk about one of the concepts that kind
of flows through the whole poster which
is
determining why you do everything we use
all these tools
you know for example in the irrigation
system why do we irrigate well we use a
soil moisture meter
we can look use our eyes look for wilt
we can use et data all this drives
why we irrigate same thing with
fertilizer right if we're trying to grow
the grass
we should kind of know how much the
grass is growing that goes back to
clipping volume
visually assessing the turf how much
it's growing and then pest control too
so why do we control pests well
presumably we're scouting to see if the
pest is there
are we using maybe some risk models
dollar spy anthracnose
brown patch models we got on our website
so we're using all these things to
determine why we're going to do
something
uh and today while we don't have
anything like this on the poster
we're going to talk about aeration rocky
had a great tweet the other day
uh informed decisions versus that's what
we've always done
and knowing knowing why you're going to
do something
uh is important you should be able to
explain why when we talk about aeration
there's a bunch of things listed here i
could have listed a bunch more but
you know why are you doing it and it's
important to think about that before
before you go and do it and say oh well
these are the eight things that it does
for me well you know
what what are you really trying to do so
knowing why we'll get into this later
frank but
um being able to explain why sometimes
through data having symmetrics
is what you should be doing before you
do any practice yeah and i think that's
just good best management practice no
matter what you're doing whether it's
for water quality
protection or managing organic matter
thanks for that carl
so let's take a little trip through the
weather uh i
unfortunately i'm on the west coast this
week so i
unfortunately didn't set my alarm i
missed my conference call this morning
where art usually gives me a good
weather report so i'm going to see what
kind of meteorologist
i can be on the fly and so the first
thing i'd start with because i'm you
know grown grass too back
east is uh the last month has felt
fairly
uh wet but the last week especially for
many has felt
a little bit on the dry side we're not
getting the amount of rainfall we've
been getting
looks like warm temperatures are coming
for the next eight to 14 days
looks like it's likely to be dry or at
least normal for some in the next
uh five days and normal uh precip
or maybe even above normal on the longer
look but maybe there's not a lot of
confidence in these things right that's
that's the that's the trick to
forecasting
one of the things that i just want to
draw your attention to because we won't
see you now or talk to you now for a
while as you go off to grow grass for
the season
um you know the dollar spot forecast uh
model we use on the website
is still a good tool to add to your
toolbox of thinking about how you're
going to make those fairway sprays
write those large acreage sprays for
this particular thing
the better you can predict and model you
know a day here a day here
a day here a day there a changing the
interval
a little bit uh altering the rate all
those practices you can look at them
in an immediate and acute level in the
model and also
art and the guys at the climate center
have built these other
forecasts where you can see what's
happened in the past and the and the
and the path moving forward so i'd
encourage you to add this to the links
on your phone
uh as well as any other tools there's
lots of them out there
certainly greenkeeper and um play
playbooks have put in the dollar spot
risk model
so so we're talking soil today and again
you know i think we were in a stall and
i think the rubber band is about to let
go we're
going to accelerate out of this stall
now and really start to get in earnest
into the growing season and you can see
the response in the soil temperatures
uh recently now well into the 60s
particularly in the metro new york area
around the urban center somewhere in
upstate new york
a little cooler in the higher elevations
but still well into the 50s where these
roots
are cranking and grass should be growing
well now typically you know
we try to remind everybody because a lot
of times in the spring this is when you
make these drench applications for these
root pathogens that are certainly among
the toughest things to control
uh that we have out there and we talk
about it ad nauseam
out here on the show and i'll just
remind everybody you know
check this publication you can go to the
wisconsin
website carl put the wisconsin website
thing in
chat or make sure we put it up there so
people can go
and access this publication online uh
check out the efficacy data you know
it's from 2020
they do it every couple of years but
this edition on the right here of
all these mixes right this is what took
a little extra time because the
pathologists
really spent some time looking at all
the new mixes have come out right
a lot of companies coming out with mixes
there's not a lot of new molecules
there's some
so what they're doing is they're doing
these blendings and then the generic
companies are doing the blendings that
are unique to them
they're mixing active ingredients in
there and again with the wide range of
efficacy among these products
you know number one use them right
number two pay attention to the frack
code
well you know the last thing we need is
getting involved in uh
uh resistance management of these things
in addition to the fact that we can't
get the darn fungicide down to the
to the organism uh where the roots are
deeper uh
without a fair amount of irrigation that
nobody likes so just a reminder about
john ingradgato's work at the university
of connecticut we've had johnny on the
show a couple of times
where we he's talked about the role of
verification in managing take all patch
in particular but the rules would so
still apply for summer patch
and he's done some work looking at none
solid and hollow tiny and
timing of the airfication the addition
or non-edition of manganese just a good
nice transition to you know the
conversation that comes up every spring
you know where where you know i think i
used this slide a bunch of weeks ago
when you know you could hear the engines
roar uh
in spring and if you look in the
background here you can see the trees
are just leafing out
in a lot of these pictures right i mean
this is early season
right then the sand starts flying we
start burying everything
you know we got john's work with the
rutgers stuff that shows
you know the role of top dressing and
managing certain stresses here like or
like anthrax it doesn't eliminate it but
it certainly
provides that protection of course you
know rock you and i have chatted about
this
more times than probably either of us
want to admit to but at the core
you know i think of what you've taught
really led the industry on over the last
decade or so has been about the you know
the relationship between managing
organic matter
and getting the water through that
profile which certainly is part
and parcel to getting fungicides down
there as well now of course that starts
with
sampling right this was really what i
thought you know i used to sit around
you and i used to argue about on this on
pti and i would sit there and listen i'm
like yeah i mean if you
can't get a good number i mean we were
yakking about this 10 years ago if you
can't get a good number
how do you know where and how and what
you're managing right and then it's okay
what's the number and then what the hell
do i do is there's 15 million ways to
put a piece of metal in the ground right
and and water injection cultivation has
gone by the wayside now you hear guys
talking about
surface area impacted right that's a
common
uh mantra i hear when i visit oh you
know i i've impacted about 13
or 20 i've gone out five times
right and now we're questioning michael
woods i know you've commented on this
uh mike is suggesting this different
approach to sampling
uh carl's done some work playing around
with the
relationship between traffic uh levels
potentially in organic matter and you
know we make a reach with this for sure
we admit it right carl so
uh and then there's all these new tools
right uh uh
the the the dry jack the the turf topper
i think which is seems to be a
a similar thing to the dry jack where
you basically
are doing water injection cultivation uh
and and
injecting sand in the hole so i got a
bunch of
simple questions here we're going to get
to but
here's the one i actually want to start
with this is what i was going to ask you
when we were bugging you a while ago
rock
you know it's spring in the north greens
are great coming out of the wind they're
firming up nice from these early season
practices guys are getting good at
we got good sands now we test that stuff
golfers are raving about condition the
next day
the greens are hollow timed and buried
in sand
why mess up good greens with spring
cultivation
frank that's a great question and it's
interesting to watch how we've gone
how we've gone along from you know
actually 73
jim baird says hey top dressing is the
best way to control
organic matter and then we get into
these really elaborate schemes right and
nothing wrong with them they all have
their twists and you know all kinds of
new devices and everything
but i've had the same question because i
think often i think we need aeration
in the seat beginning of the season but
not like immediately because
the grass is ready to go right and we're
taking advantage and especially this
year it looked like your data was
similar i took a look at some of your
previous data we had this warming trend
and then the bottom dropped out right
and we saw lots of injury you know we
had you know 28 degrees
after people had already started mowing
and
for the great claims that's pretty
catastrophic and a lot of weird
discoloration and everyone was reaching
for
fungicides mostly homeowners but they're
like hey well how do i control this
whiting whitening of the leaf and it
looks like ascochyta and
blah blah so so i'm not convinced that
we should be jumping on the aeration but
i do believe it's because of players
right because our play goes down you
know we get a we get a jump a play
and then they're trying to take i think
the superintendent is trying to take
advantage of that
little gap in play before it really hits
the season but is that agronomically
sound uh seems to me that we could get
some play on it
and i know the guys that top dress is a
means of for winter management right
they put a bunch of top dressing sand on
there
you know that they pretty much drag that
in with sand reels and
and and maybe do a little spiking or
something like that to get it in
but those guys don't normally go
especially out in western nebraska they
don't normally go with a
with a real aggressive coring
matter of fact a lot of them aren't even
pulling a core anymore at all right okay
wait
we're gonna get to that so let me
interrupt here and ask you know
get into the heart of it number one
you're right if you
don't time spring air if you first off
if you think you need spring
verification whether it's hollow tine or
solid kind
and you do it at a time that you don't
get active growth you're staring at
pretty bad looking holes bumpy greens
for a couple of weeks that's what you're
describing there
that's the that's number one what
aggravates the golfers further because
i also hear guys that wait and they're
like frank
i just look what i just did it was six
days ago and they're completely covered
because if you hit the growth potential
right
right they're filled back in but here's
here's the thing i want to
want to have a laugh about it's i say
okay
so what if you didn't do it like oh oh
i'm going to get play i got to do it i
got to
well what if you didn't do it oh oh and
so
okay if top dressing is the way i manage
organic matter
and i got sands integrated into the
organic matter i got my numbers at like
two percent like most guys
who are still worried and and they're
saying oh if i don't do it it feels like
it's like jumping off a cliff or
something whoa here i go
no spring verification no parachute tell
me
uh how do we ease that for people how do
we tell them really you know you
probably
you know if you really got to do
something get a really thin needle and
just go up and down quick
and i don't know how do you want to
answer that
no and once again another great idea and
i'm convinced that we
pull for aggressive verification if the
green has problems
and they need you know five six seven
who knows what the magic number is
you and i have talked about that there
is really no magic number but if they're
down around two two and a half which is
what we see as a routine average on
greens that are managed
you know moderately well right i mean
all across and doug lindy's work shows
that and
the usg work shows that so so let's quit
obsessing about a number
and and then not worry about it in the
spring you know you can do needle times
you can do band that time you can do
these less aggressive verification get
sand into the profile without
you know 5 8 times when when we are
questioning whether the grass is going
to grow yet
wow i i just don't get that i i don't
i struggle with that all right so let's
let's let's take this a little bit at a
time here and go
back to um some of the questions that i
listed here first off it's the number
right
then you know the interesting evolution
of this now seems to be well maybe we
need the number more at the surface
right you questioned this immediately
when you did your research years ago
right
right where do we sample from so now the
question's coming again and so
for now what's the best method in your
mind that's going to give
superintendents actionable data what is
the kind of actionable
sample data they can get from sampling
do you like the undisturbed core
just in the top three centimeters do you
think it's just
maybe you should start getting these
om246 numbers
to see if they tell us anything right
i'm not presuming they can tell us
anything yet but what do you think
well no and you know the i mean michael
woods popularized the
sex sectionalized sampling it's not new
i mean people have been doing it
some of the labs do that etc etc but he
gave it a nice hashtag and
you know rolls it to the surface and now
we have an opportunity to look at that
and
you know clearly and the usj you know
dave otis who's now retired from the
usga he's like
yeah i worry about what's in you know
that little the edge
you know if i'm squeezing water at that
you know 12 4
24 hours after an irrigation that's a
problem so
really maybe we need to concentrate on
that i don't think the data is clear
on that yet and i did want an
opportunity to talk about the
usga they're calling it the brain trust
i'm not sure with me being on that that
counts but
you know it's me doug soldat doug lindy
um
jim murphy you know and we are all doing
this
we did a lit review and we found out all
the gaps in sampling
and then doug is starting to receive
samples from us to look at that
first inch and whether we can
consistently sample and whether we leave
the verdure on and off and you know the
usga is generously well not generously
they're sort of funding it but
you know we are getting some dollars for
it to pay the bills yeah you guys you
still got the god you stood you stopped
you still got it you still got a guy you
still got the godfather in there somehow
hey i'm gonna take that right that's a
good thing that's right
all right so so that the bottom line is
frank bottom line is is that
i think we're going to be we're going to
we're going to quit thinking like
farmers
and come up with a sampling technique
that makes
sense for golf green specific or
sportster
right and maybe how we sample by depth
and maybe and i think you'll see that
within
maybe within a year we will have that
either in the green section or one
some publication where we'll say a
standardized method for sampling golf
greens
because we needed that we needed that 20
years ago
hello yeah i can't wait so let me let's
ask the next question because
okay we're going to have numbers in a
couple of years if you and i are still
at this
we'll come back there'll be some numbers
we'll be able to have targets
maybe it'll matter from that perspective
how to calibrate this use of sand
right so what about what you revealed
when you looked back and said you know
if you put enough sand down matched to
your growth
uh you're pretty good so what do you
think about
what do you say to people now that are
considering
eliminating cultivation in many ways and
just going with growth driven
top dressing which to me implies they're
collecting clippings they're monitoring
the organic matter
and they're adding sand accordingly
versus having to make a hole and put the
sand in what are your thoughts
it was a pain in the butt when you did
it right this harkens back to your work
no it and it you know it was hard to
sell number one when we showed that
solid times are just as good as hollow
and people started saying well what
about compaction you're not removing any
material
you're not removing them even when
people say 20
those holes fill up with organic matter
right so so i struggle with that all the
time
but at the same time i'm just not
convinced that we can't manage
organic matter you know we're not
talking about compaction sands
don't readily compact we're talking
about that top
inch or top two inches whatever we come
up with that's why we build them out of
these things that's why normal made a
damn career out of this because
we engineered the damn sands we just
keep sanding
moisture off the surface and the organic
matter compromises that so manage the
organic matter
so that it doesn't stay at the surface
firm and fast or high and dry
whatever buzzword you want to use or
hashtag you want to use
but do we need cultivation for that i'm
i'm not convincing
i think we need the top dressing i know
some of my very respected
superintendents out there are like hey
we don't need to top dress or they're
top dressing minimally
um but you need some sand on the surface
and you need to keep the surface firm
and fast right
so if i but but but the idea now
is if i can really keep growth
to a minimum heavy trim it use a new you
name it the group pgr
you know we get a little nervous when
they drive to end down low
but we know they keep the putting
surfaces dry at a very high level
they'll try to keep them as dry as
possible
so they've got everything they can do to
ratchet down growth
again it drives it's two things number
one
it's they don't recover as well from
traffic and that's where i want to go
next
but also you know if they're not growing
maybe they don't need as much sand
no and i but i think people are getting
really good at not putting on as much
sand when we look at
surveys that paul vermillion did you
know 30 25 30 years ago
and and you know there were areas
putting on 60 to 80 cubic yards on an
end you know
down in florida and stuff and and now we
see people in the 10
to 20 range you know our recommendation
in generic terms was
around 18 to 22 right i think we're
lower than we were and when you look at
the early recommendations
they were 20 to 60 cubic yards i mean
that's that's
it 20 or or is it 60. okay so
can you give me you know i i really
appreciated the usgas or this method
they've come up with with the sheet pan
and the mat on top
to figure out depth i want to know
i'm you know it's like i finally figured
out why i don't entirely understand top
dressing other than i'm an idiot
i need somebody to tell me how much
depth you put on every year i remember
when the pacific northwest
guys were doing the worm work years ago
right
you know god rest his soul paul backman
i think did some of that work
where they were putting on a half an
inch a year on the fairways right
rock remember that oh yeah so so what is
30
i mean when i try to think about this
what are some
targets that guys are adding in depths
in in your mind
over the course of a year 30 versus 60
cubic yards
yeah so i mean you know we know our work
at 20 i mean we've got this measured as
actually what happened um you know
you're putting on at 20
18 to 20 you're putting on about um
about .6 to 1.2
centimeters about a half an inch a year
okay
yeah at that rate okay so so here's the
question now since we brought it up
what about traffic carl's carl's really
been fussing around with this
looking at uh organic matter levels in
our you know putting greens on these
state park golf courses where he's
getting more extensive this year doing
it
um what do you make it at what do you
make of the impact and why would traffic
reduce organic matter
well i think we actually shear roots and
and we
physically kill it right i mean we're
lack of a better term and
i know that when we look at courses that
have 60 to 80
000 rounds versus courses that have 30
they consistently have less organic
matter
and then when we sample in approaches or
entry extra points on a green
those can be down one percent and then
the rest of the green is at three to
three and a half
traffic does you know some more rounds i
like the graph you showed of carl's work
it's because
clearly there's less organic matter when
you traffic it more you know i wonder
what about triflex versus walk behinds
you know
there's a lot of opportunity here for
data-driven science but who's going to
do it
well that's right and i can tell you
sometimes you just
uh necessity is the mother of invention
we're talking to our
i'm talking to my our pal dan dinelli
and he says you know i
i i got sick uh the the mower on the
approach the triplex in the approach so
i told the fiveflex guy to just
drive up there don't drive on the green
figure out how to swoop through and he
swears
if the approaches got firmer he swears
that there's less top dressing needed
so listen let's stop here carl i'm sure
this is usually a lively topic
this gets usually people at least a
question or two how about you
comments or questions for rock yeah you
know the one thing when we talk about
traffic i think with golfers we normally
think of just walking
or push card walk off walk off what
we've been
doing frank is we've been looking at
trying to estimate how many pitch marks
basically a golfer will make over the
course of a round and
you know based on how big the green is
and how many golfers are going through
you can see on average between three and
eight percent of your surface
on a whole grain impacted by a pitch
mark in a given year
um so basically you know diameter of the
ball
you know how many pitch marks around
blah blah blah but
that's probably a significant impact on
traffic too and i don't think we think
about that
until we see all the unfixed pitch marks
people put the flags out they do a
little demonstration so
maybe just a psa for for your for your
golfers to fix their pitch marks maybe
that'll help out
amen to that um but uh so we did have a
couple questions from vitas one
um he's asking about sand top dressing
leading to hydrophobicity
uh any other concerns there rocker frank
yeah of course well and i think it's you
know when we try to keep them drier
you know the drier you keep any sand the
potential for
you know then they start repelling sand
so i think the answer is
is it possible to keep grains too dry
you know even if you're keeping them
alive and i've seen greens in that
condition
and then when when they're trying to wet
them up you know they're getting ready
for a tournament or whatever
when they're trying to wet them up they
don't wet up right or the wall you can
actually see the water repealing
off the surface and then they go pound
them with wetting agents and we don't
have time to have a conversation about
lighting agents
but but you know clearly they find a way
to get water into the surface
so yeah the question is or the answer is
yes that
the drier you keep sands the more apt
they are to be
hydrophobic exactly right and
you're exactly right rock the wetting
agent hole is
uh one i went down a little bit with
glenn o'beer earlier this year and it
still remains
uh a very personal thing for every
superintendent other questions carl
uh yeah my test is also asking uh loss
on ignition combustion testing
uh i know brock you're probably playing
around i think the temperatures of what
they were burning the organic matter
samples is
this may be changing i don't know if
you've solidified that with this usga
work or if that's something you're
investigating as well
yeah so so that's a great question and i
think it was one that was created
because people found out that they are
done it fired at different temperatures
you know
calcareous temperatures do respond
differently but but the
the temperature that we've came about
based on all the data that was out there
and there's a fair amount of data
in agricultural soils and to a limited
extent um you know we came up with a
temperature and when we release the
specs we'll have a range but within that
range you're fine
but this obsession with the temperature
i think was predicated on people looking
for something to
question right i i don't i think we've
well i think we've solidified a
temperature
the whole sampling depth and how you
sample and leaving the verdura on or off
let's we'll try to finalize that but i
think we've got a temperature that's
solid
and we can trust that 99.9
of the greens that are sampled that are
sand-based that'll give you a reasonable
estimate of
using loi all right so so last question
from me rock before we wrap up here
is um these new tools what i call new
tools right i i've been a big fan
of the dry jack mostly because i was a
big fan of the hydro jet
uh before that got pulled and it seemed
to me man putting the sand in a hole
in a water injection hole that does its
thing boy that feels good because i know
your data also revealed that but you
know i haven't
honestly i can't say i've seen data but
i've walked on greens where guys have
gotten on these programs and man
it seems that that works now the other i
will call a new tool is the air 2g
i know johnny soraka's been playing
around with that and
talking about a little short-lived you
know
we have this obsession continued
obsession
for new tools on sand-based greens and
i gotta tell you pal i haven't
reconciled why we need to have all these
tools
when we build these things design these
things to
resist the compaction beyond uh just
targeted spots like carl talks about
walk on walk off
uh you know where you had to put the cup
a lot where you get a lot of foot
traffic
that kind of thing what are your
thoughts about new tools the need for
any tools and
why bother when you got sand-based
greens well no and i i think when we see
the hydrogen most effective
is courses that have not consistently
top-dressed and you know superintendents
have changed a lot of turnover
and i think the hydro i i you know i i
think they work amazing right because
they get a lot of sand into the profile
they're less disruptive than
you know once again my least favorite
kind is the 5 8 right you know and
i mean go big or go home no i don't
think you need that but anyway
um so i've seen greens really torn up
and heaved when they eat so
but if you've got a green that's got
been compromised by layering and
and you know excessive nitrogen so you
get those multiple growing layers even
though the greens were built 30 years
ago
right you get that you know cake steve
keeley
layers are for cakes not for greens
right and
there's some amazing pictures on on
twitter of people showing you know
20 21 20 40 whatever your greens
so so i'm not sure i i think they really
work great in those arenas
and then as a management tool with a
little less aggressive approach
and you know the guys that run that
company do a really good job
i don't know anything about the air 2g i
know a little bit about it
i know like johnny's working in sports
turf
you know it's clearly showing some
benefits but
you know are they long-term or not and
he himself have said that so
just like you said but i'm not sure we
i'm not sure from the general day-to-day
operations
of a green that's been managed what we
would say quote unquote correctly
that's not layered and doesn't have an
excessive organic matter whether we just
can't do
my favorite is needle times in the
quadratic set right
and just poke holes and throw sand
and no one noticed no one even knew you
were there no that
you know that you could if you put just
a minimal sand on you can water it in
and nobody knows you're there right
exactly right
and nobody's disruption yeah you're a
man
so great to see you we're at the
witching hour carl for the end of our
season
man 11 weeks
it's not only the fastest 30 minutes
it's the fastest 11 weeks we are
bending the space time continuum carl
yep thanks thanks everybody for joining
us we'll have one more episode tomorrow
with the
chase straw we'll talk about some remote
sensing on sports turf
uh but brock again thanks for the time
today i'm happy to finally get it done
all right rock
see everybody tomorrow thanks everybody
thanks very much take care appreciate it
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu